I think that this this pushing the
envelope is part of us and I think the
people who make the most money happen
are kind of sometimes they are unbridled
examples of this that they're run away
examples of pushing and pushing and
pushing
William how are you I'm okay I know the
world you know this is what I say to
everybody I'm fine I dread to think
what's gonna happen next
the world is in a you know very peculiar
state it's for me it's the same and
doing the same thing as I always do
which is try and think of things too
right sit at home go for walks you know
meet the same few people socially
distance now although obviously not
things like my son and that sort of
thing but my life's more or less the
same but I know that loads of people are
either I just had this conversation I
suppose I must have it every every day
because it is the conversation to have
your either some people are locked in a
situation they hate some people have to
go to work and put themselves in
terrible danger anyway so I keep
thinking of that but you know like you
said it's lovely whether you can go for
walks and my life's the same so I agree
I keep on saying it to people that I
appreciate for some it might be
challenging but for me it's not a
massive difference from what I'm used to
you know I've got slightly fewer people
to see slightly more time to read and a
little bit worse internet connection
because everybody's on online but yeah
yeah other than that it's all good
so today we're talking about money very
sort of passionate topic a very
viscerally emotion inducing topic we're
talking about why some people can make
it another's can't it's what it's it's a
very weird thing money because you think
you know what it is you spend your whole
life with this concept of money you know
you've got it you haven't got it what is
it oh it's what's in my pocket
and then when you try and sort of drill
down into it try and understand what it
is how it arose what it does to your
head then it becomes this very weird
thing and I realized that quite quickly
that's why I wanted to write about it
because I didn't understand it
there was a big you know the global
financial crash and I think that wasn't
the very first time I'd thought about
money because I'd once tried to write
about it and found after writing I wrote
a 1200 word article on the origins of
money from first principles and I
thought God not going there again
so weird and then we had this big crash
and I realized that there was something
wrong with you know money was something
that really helped us and really enabled
all sorts of things to happen but there
was something deeply wrong with it and I
wondered what that was and was there a
way I could simply understand it was
there a simple way to understand what
was wrong so after that I began to think
about it a bit and I was thinking yeah
money cut I could write about that no I
couldn't no no and then one day and I
realized all this time I kept
interviewing these people who made tons
of money and I would say you know how
did you make this money and it's almost
like you're asking somebody hey your
Gardens tidy how did you do that and
they say well you see that grass I got
this mower I mowed it and then I painted
the shed like all this and you ask
people how they make money and they go
well first of all I thought yeah I you
know what's what's going on in the hi-fi
market and then I thought yeah I could
make it a bit cheaper you think yeah
that's a good point yeah and then I made
a bit cheaper and how much do you make
oh you know like ten million so you
think the people who make a load of
money they they sort of understand it
and it seems like this logical thing but
for 99.9% of us it's um it's not logical
and you know obviously if you could do
it if you could do it you would and I
couldn't do it and I actually had some
pathological problem with money which is
that even when I made a load of it
it would somehow get into me and change
me so I'd become this person who had
some money and then it would all be gone
because identifying as yourself with
your money it's terrible
you've got to be the person who doesn't
have money and then have the money so I
thought my problem with money was a bit
like you know I mean I'm what you call
it
reformed alcoholic I'm a banty total
first seven and a half years amazing
congratulations
well I wouldn't you know and I know that
I can't touch alcohol
you're drinking what is it an energy
drink oh this is this note there's no
caffeine in this although shout out to
knock oh thank you for supporting the
podcast but this is just some BCAAs
flavored flavored elderflower nothing
nothing to accelerate right so I'd had
this you know and anything that sort of
that sped life up whether it was you
know cocaine was that I had a terrible
thing with that alcohol somehow I would
be unable to the person who had had the
substance was seemed to be not me but
some raging crazy person so like two
drinks and the chance I have a third
drink is very high three drinks and the
chance I have a fourth drink is so high
that all bets are off and then where do
I wake up I don't know so so and I had
that relationship with money which is
like oh I've got some money you know I
could have this I could have that well
why not oh it's all gone
well I'll borrow some anyway so
obviously there was some sort of drug
like quality to it and it became part of
you it becomes part of you because it's
like the way I explain it is it's like
part of you is a bully and is saying go
on have this have this and another part
of you is like well I guess I could
could have that and you buy yourself out
of every you know oh I'll go to both
parties and then I'll get a taxi back
rather than you have to make a choice
you know which party you're going to go
to so I knew I had a problem with it
which was even more reason to to write
about it to try and sort of study it and
I kept on interviewing these people and
I thought yeah they do tell me how they
make money but I'd like to think about
this a bit more and the turning point
came when I interviewed Jordan Belfort
who was the who is the person who was
portrayed by Leonardo DiCaprio in the
film The Wolf of Wall Street did you did
you interview him before you knew you
were going to write the trake basically
the story was that I had got a contract
to write a book about money and I and I
didn't know how to do it so I wouldn't
mate are you there I've heard you did
okay with money it was well the thing is
you did okay with money but it also had
a terrible problem with it and I
realized that he was he was everything
that he was the confusion in one person
which is how do you make a hundred
million but then why when you've made a
hundred million do you commit a fraud
that might well land you in jail for
money that you could never spend so I
thought here's here's something that's
interesting because he's got a real gift
for making money but it's almost like
why would you then commit a fraud why
would you then you know put yourself at
that risk of going to jail if somebody
catches you which they did so I thought
that was really interesting so I I spent
a few days with him and he was
rehabilitating himself actually in in a
way that was quite admirable you know
he's he's really
he owes a hundred million at this point
and he's wanting to teach people how to
make money and he's got this great
confidence and this great salesmanship
and he's - he's telling me that the
greatest part of his life was when he
had this company and he had this roomful
of brokers and he was every day giving
them these talks to inspire them to
motivate them and whatever he said
worked and he wanted to get back to
being that person because that was where
it really that was one of the things
that it was for him was the ability to
be on stage and talk to people about how
to pull off some some trick and and this
was them or a series of tricks which was
how to buy stocks and then get other
people to buy them so they were worth
more and that works to a certain extent
and then he he met somebody who said do
you know what you can do if you want to
do even better you can actually pay
people to buy the stocks and then tell
them when to sell them and you you can
then manipulate the market in a way
which is completely illegal so he did
the completely illegal thing and and was
caught and went to jail and so here he
was after this had happened in his new
life doing a similar thing of getting up
in front of people and saying this is
what you have to do if you want to make
money and one of the things was don't
let your stupid emotions get in the way
another of the things the overriding
thing I think and this comes you
mentioned Nassim Taleb who we'll get to
but what he said to me the first thing I
remember he said was
when you get rich you get rich quick but
that's not at the start you have to do
an awful lot of things before it kicks
in but when it kicks in it happens very
fast in other words you're gonna spend a
long time putting all these pieces
together working out what it is you have
to do and if you do it a bit wrong it
nothing happens
and if you don't do all of it nothing
happens you have to get this complicated
series of things to work but then when
you do everything happens so it's a bit
like this is not a linear thing you go
along and I thought to myself it's a bit
like learning a language right
you're translating the language into
your own language and it seems all very
stilted and every day you learn a new
word and every week you learn a new bit
of grammar but basically nothing much
happens and you think will I ever get
anywhere and then one day somehow it
clicks and you realize you've got to
think in the new language and then you
start
oh god that's what it is this isn't it's
painstaking bit of translation it's not
it's not you know it's not all these
labels it's it's not the same world that
with with all these labels on it it's a
different world and the labels are
different and the way they thinks a bit
different but once you've accepted that
and you see that you're in that new
world so I thought that's probably how
people get rich it's it's it's a complex
set of things and if you read genuinely
good self-help books ones that don't say
here's a magic here's a bit of magic you
just need to like concentrate on money
and it will come through your door what
would you put into that category can you
put your where your mouth is with that
yeah I'm saying it's it's something like
the slight edge by Jeff Olson basically
says you're gonna if you want to succeed
at something you're gonna have to learn
all about it so let's say you wanted to
learn a language or let's say you wanted
to learn the you know how to run a
garden centre or whatever it is you're
selling yeah well anything you want to
do you have to learn about it and you're
gonna start learning about it and
there's gonna be a period in the middle
where you don't seem to be getting
anywhere because you you're not you
don't seem to be making any progress but
actually all the work you're putting in
now and will be putting in for the next
couple of years is gonna pay dividends
actually when everything comes together
you're gonna be glad you did all that
learning so you've got to think with the
idea of there's gonna be a future me who
knows how to you know make a film write
a book whatever it is but at the but
there's going to be many many days when
you feel oh this isn't working and a
house how can I move forward so
basically that's how almost everything
seems to work and that that's the that's
the kind of big lesson that if you want
to do something you've got to do it over
and over
it's the Malcolm Gladwell 10,000 hours
it's not entirely that because you well
he does say Malcolm Gladwell does say
you've got to have feedback you've got
to learn
and I realized also that this is very
much like science right it's all about
looking for patterns you have a you have
a hypothesis it's not necessarily your
belief it's something that you're saying
might be the case and then you try and
disprove it and you set up all these
experiments to say why doesn't this work
and eventually the thing that your
hypothesis might survive and then you
know that you might be getting closer to
the truth so it's kind of like all of
these people and all of these people
that I interviewed had a method that was
a bit like that they they they I mean I
didn't put this in because there was
just so much of it but I'd spent about a
year studying Warren Buffett Warren
Buffett great guy him and Charlie Munger
are both fan favorites from this show
right ok so the thing that impressed me
I mean lots of things I mean he's
obviously a very strange and very
unusual guy and you realize that when he
went to when he went to Columbia when he
went to university is it the the Wharton
College is that well he went to the
Wharton and then he went to Columbia and
he met Benjamin Graham who was the guy
who wrote the intelligent investor and I
think Graham would he had a class of
people and he would you know say well
let's talk about the insurance industry
or something and the sort of student age
Buffett would know all about it and
would say yeah well I would say that
this company's doing this and next month
we'll see that and Benjamin Graham was
like I beg your pardon you know what all
this stuff but what impressed me what
was incredible is that I remember I did
this thing where I got all the sources I
could find and I imagine a day in his
life when he was 16 and I think he ran
11 businesses when he was 16
and they weren't major businesses one
was a car wash business where he hired
kids to wash cars and actually there
came a point when he dumped that because
it wasn't making enough money he had a
golf-ball business where he realized
that you could [ __ ] you could go to a
golf course in Nebraska and you could go
into the lake where they that there were
these sunk got you know sunk costs that
the golf balls are all gone you could
get somebody to get the golf balls from
the bottom of the lake and then you
could post them to some golf
but second-hand golf ball guy in
Illinois where people paid more for golf
balls so you could you know you could
just hire people to to get golf balls
and then tonight unitive in a lake
somewhere in wherever it was he was here
and yeah and there were there were stamp
collections you know he realized that a
full collection of stamps was worth it
you know two hundred dollars but a
collection with ten stamps missing was
worth five dollars so he would then look
at the the sorts of stamps that needed
to be that that most collections were
missing and he'd make up the collection
you know and he did he did ten or eleven
of these things all the time when he was
sixteen so he was constantly running
these businesses made more money than
his teachers his parents extraordinary
and what he was learning was how
businesses worked from the ground up she
got an incredible view of what a
business was trying to do and how the
people who ran it were contributing to
it and how they were frittering things
away or not so he would homed in on what
really worked about the business so when
he started buying businesses he had an
incredible sort of gut sense you know
he'd he'd spend a day with people you
know tell me about your day tell me what
you're buying and he would really get a
sense of how they worked and so that's
learning isn't it that's making it a
science it's kind
imbibing it so I think what one of the
interesting things about that that I've
been thinking about recently is because
of the imbalance because of how
disproportionately we see people's
successes and not their grinds and
failures before they are successful we
don't get to see the handle of the
hockey stick yeah we just get to see the
head yes so are the people that are
listening if you can imagine a graph and
it's the shape of a hockey stick laid on
its side and it's going along and it's
flat and it's flat and it's flat and
then it just kicks up and it hits a hit
a inflection point right tipping point
as it might yeah yeah yeah and um the
best because it's rare that you have in
normal day-to-day life like my mom
doesn't have a graph of the stuff
happening in her life you know like how
maybe how much she's meditating if she
uses the headspace app sufficiently mom
keep using the headspace up but very
often you don't have an objective
measure however I have done and it's
been this podcast and I promise you it's
the shape of a hockey stick it's the
shape of a argues that you do tons and
tons and tons and tons of work and not
really that much happens and then
something happens and it just goes whoop
and there's a quote that James clear
uses I can't remember the American
football teams someone who's listening
will know the one that I mean there's an
American football team who has on their
wall a quote about a stonemason and they
say we know that it isn't the hundredth
hit which snaps the stone we know it is
the 99 which came before the point with
that is that it takes a lot of time to
become an overnight success yeah yeah
and all of the things that we've come up
with this or Jordan Belfort's someone
who started off with Penny Stocks he
learned from the ground floor up anybody
that's seen the movie knows this then he
starts to hone his craft onstage in
front of a big group of people then
moving forward he even repurposes that
now now that he's barred from operating
in the financial sector
he now repurposes that then you've got
somebody like Warren Buffett who runs so
many businesses I found out the other
day Warren Buffet more in business
Warren Buffett has 90 percent of his net
worth attributed to 10 trades yeah yeah
I can imagine that 90 percent of his net
worth attributed to 10 investments
unbelievable so we've got these people
who are all showing the same thing and
yet all of us yourself me everyone is
seduced by the idea of get rich fast the
10 minute booty abs blaster workout -
yeah Alenia your bum out in this time
despite the fact that we are shown time
and time and time again that the way to
become an overnight success is actually
to just grind away at something
effectively with a feedback mechanism
making sure you're doing deliberate
practice for a long time I I want I mean
I once saw I don't know if you follow
football that thing that used to happen
but the former England player Rio
Ferdinand was once asked who is the best
player that you ever played with that
you ever you know trained with or played
with and he said and I've forgotten the
name of this guy he said it's
such-and-such and it's not a familiar
name and so the interviewer said yeah I
kind of remember him didn't he play a
few games for West Ham or whatever new
he goes yeah yeah he's got so much
natural talent this this guy and you
know he'd had his career he was now
about 30 odd and but he said this guy
was he had more talent than anybody I've
ever played you what you mean even so
and so yeah yeah this guy was really
extraordinary and so the interview said
well what happened him what why you know
he obviously could play in a Premier
League but why didn't he
why don't we all know his name and he
said well
he didn't have the same work ethic as
all these other people it's like you
know you you have to train every day you
have to stay behind after training if
you've got a bit of a you know if your
fitness isn't quite there you have to
try again and again and again and maybe
you're gonna have to work on this move
or that move and everybody who succeeds
does that and a pure ability isn't quite
enough even if you train harder you have
beats talent when talent didn't work
hard
yes yes exactly if this guy had trained
maybe he would be better than anybody he
would have been better this is what Rio
Ferdinand was suggesting but you know
it's not that these other guys weren't
brilliant it's just that this guy didn't
you know he worked 95% but not 99% and
it's that last little bit that's where
the growth occurs as well right and also
as you start to see as with anything if
there's a bail distribution of normal
right looked on to the tails the further
that you can push yourself out towards
them the fewer people you are going to
have to compete with by definition right
so right I want you to tell us about the
Russian half billionaire and his Butler
please so we've learned about Jordan
Belfort who's this who's this Russian
what's this this guy the interesting
thing about this guy somebody was saying
to me this guy lives in the nicest house
in you know the country maybe the world
it's it's this house a very special
house that was built in 1698 or said it
took a few years 1700 and it was built
by Nicholas Hawksmoor the famous
architect but it was originally designed
by Christopher Wren the famed most
famous architect in history and and Wren
passed the project on and between them
they managed to concoct this beautiful
house and it has beautiful grounds and
it has you know
avenue of trees and the amazing
reflecting pool so that you can stand
behind the house and you can see it
doubled in this reflecting pool and it's
everything is thought of where is it
it's it's in Northamptonshire
okay and why is it like what makes it so
special like it's just pretty in its gob
it's it's it's beautiful it's it's um
it's if you imagine something like
Buckingham Palace but smaller and
prettier pretty big pretty high bar to
set that yeah yeah it's kind it's kind
of it's a lot smaller than Buckingham
Palace but it's it's got perfect
dimensions and all these architecture
critics would say this this house is
it's one of the best houses they've made
so I was interested in the fact that
some Russian guy had bought it and I
thought who is he and so they gave me
this story to go and spend a day at this
house of this Russian guy and it was odd
that the whole thing was odd because he
he'd made us an awful lot of money in
the in the rag trade clothes and he had
these these concessions in department
stores all over the world and a lot of
stores in China a lot of stores all over
the Far East a lot in America and he had
somehow he dialed he he'd found the
point at which the how expensive it was
to make something compared to how many
you sell compared to the price point you
sell it at and he's got this computer
like brain and so and I said to him
ma'am you sound a bit like Ingvar
Kamprad you know because I once did this
thing on IKEA
I couldn't can't Brad wouldn't see me
but he actually let you know I stayed in
some nice house on the lake somewhere in
Sweden and I did meet his designers and
the story about Kamprad is that you know
the designer could show him a table
here's a table and say it's made out of
you know teak or it well it's made out
of Oh
whatever it is you know pine it's made
out of pine and in this is how big it is
and Kamprad would look at it and his
brain would go I'd get the pine from the
Ukraine and then that would be such and
such a tongue and if we made you know
ten thousand tables that would cost this
much per table and the trucking costs
but then we'd have to buy in in Swedish
crowns and then we'd have to sell in you
know whatever it is and then we'd we'd
blah blah blah and then the the petrol
costs and he would his mind will be
buzzing with all these things and then
he would just say to the guy okay do it
no this one's not gonna fly because he
would look at everything and he he would
just be working out the whole supply
chain and that's when he was going this
I said for this to the Russian guy he
said yeah that's exactly me you know he
thinks about where you can get the
cotton and who you can which Factory
with it he has loads of factories in
China you know which one would it go to
and and then where would I sell it this
would be good for Los Angeles stores and
it would be good for the blah and then
you'd sell it for $600 yeah we'll do it
so we've still got here an unbelievable
dexterity and kind of depth of
understanding of their own operation you
know you look at these people who make a
lot of cash and sometimes you can
discount them as just lucky fortunate
idiots it doesn't sound like you really
doesn't sound like this Russian guy or
Jordan Belfort is is one of them know
all of these people I mean including
Allen sugar and including Howard Schultz
and Inc these people that I interviewed
they all looked at their business with a
real depth of understanding you know
Howard Schultz and his coffee shops how
much how much per square foot would you
get back if you rented this how many how
much would you have to make you know he
knew all that and you put comfortable
chairs and you change it a little bit
and he managed to he had a
an idea that if you if you made coffee
shops a little tiny bit more like bars
you'd get all the business for coffee
well and he was right
who does Alan Schultz own Howard Schultz
he is Starbucks he was the guy who
started Starbucks okay and and and again
he's one of these guys he's that he's
obviously brilliant so many of these
guys they've got a sort of they remember
everything and they it's almost like and
it's like with Talib and his in his um
his graphs and you know you can see him
thinking about like mathematical
equations and he can sort of almost draw
them there in his head he lives them
it's not like I mean he understands the
the value how options are priced and how
likely or unlikely something's about
some something is to happen and
therefore how much you should spend on
predicting that it would happen so what
tell me you just tell me what it was
like being in this building then this
Russian guy who's he there was well as I
say he he was living in this vast estate
at the time with his Butler he it was
him and his Butler and the thing I found
one else no no one else well he was he
he would sometimes get models to try on
his clothes and he would have these he
ended up marrying one of them not the
one that was there the day I was there
incidentally but it struck me that he
was plowing a lonely furrow in a way but
but in this extraordinary luxury and he
said to me he was going to have dinner
and I said to the butler you're gonna
cook him dinner and he said yeah I
always cook him dinner I said what you
do the two of you just sit around eating
and he goes oh no I eat in the servants
quarters and so so interesting isn't I
know so the guy the guy had a church as
well on his on his land
in his grounds lovely old church and
it's like you've got a church you
haven't got a congregation you in there
so something I've been thinking about a
lot recently as well actually is the
price that you need to pay for someone's
success so people might look at Nassim
Taleb or this Russian billionaire half
billionaire or Conor McGregor or some
Instagram model or whatever and say I
want that but they don't understand the
price that you need to pay not as in the
long hours and stuff like that but the
pathologies that come along with having
a mindset which permits you to do the
thing which you think is good right what
is the price that you need to pay
psychologically biologically routine
wise in terms of your sleep in terms of
your mental health in terms of the
thoughts that go through your head when
your head hits the pillow at night all
of those things right like what what is
the price that this Russian half
billionaire has to pay in order to be
such a complete sort of crazy advanced
thinker with regards to his exactly that
the best case I had of that was Felix
Dennis his who was he made about the
same amount of money about it in in
pounds about probably four or five
hundred million pounds that sort of
thing and he he had this big estate in
Warwickshire and he also had an that was
the only place of his I went to and I
went to hit to it twice anybody also had
places he had an estate in the Caribbean
and he had one in Connecticut and he had
various houses but when I went to his
estate in Warwickshire which was his
kind of main place
there was that he'd he'd got these he
got an avenue of statues which led up to
this kind of barn that he'd converted
into this kind of luxurious crazy a
place where he sat and contemplated and
wrote poetry and that kind of stuff and
the line of statues and you know who
Commission's full-size statues these
days well it he's dead now but it was
him and the odd kind of dictator but not
not many people and at the very end of
this Avenue was this a pond
and a statue of Icarus plunging to his
death the person who in legend had flown
too close to the Sun which I thought was
a bit odd because you know he himself
had done all this unfettered
capitalistic making these these great
moves and tons of money and yet the
thing that was outside his his very the
place he went to think was a warning the
warning don't do this too much so I went
in there and I asked him about this and
and he said he thought that making money
was he kind of said you know it had
driven him insane in a way it had driven
him crazy he'd become a crack addict he
he'd had an existential crisis which
lasted four years he'd nearly killed
himself and arguably did kill himself
with all the crack smoking because he
ended up dying of lung cancer so the
surely that had something to do with
years of smoking crack and and and he
said yeah he'd made himself into a
different person
I personally didn't like you know this
person who who was hard driving and
obsessive and permanently focused on how
to make money how he could get an
advantage in the market of whatever it
was he was doing and in a way he you
sort of think well he'd made like four
hundred and fifty million quid or
whatever but he should have stopped at
fifty that last four hundred what was
that worth to him it had it had done him
in so why do you think he kept going
well this is that this is the big
question and it's acquaint it's a bit
like a question for the human race you
know we want more and more luxury and
we're prepared to go to the very edge of
our own sanity and also our own you know
were prepared to take big risks to get
just a little bit more we're prepared to
we will say well I've heard that these
forests
crucial to the Earth's upkeep but hell
we want a bit more luxury so let's chop
them down and see if we can get away
with it we might we might find a way of
tweaking it so that we're all right so I
think I think that this this pushing the
envelope is part of us and I think the
people who make the most money happen
are kind of sometimes they are unbridled
examples of this that they're run away
examples of pushing and pushing and
pushing and also I mean I'm going to use
an analogy of drinking which isn't
necessarily the same but the writer and
drinker Kingsley Amis once said it's not
about being drunk
it's about getting drunk so the process
of getting drunk that the constant
change up from being less sober unless I
mean being drunk you can keep that it's
getting drunk that's the thing and so
these people if you think about it the
best time they ever had in their life
was when they were on that curve the
hockey stick was going right up now they
cut how do they keep going they don't
they don't want to stop and say do you
know what let's have another infinity
pool let's let's commission a few more
statues that's part of the in a way the
pathology the thing that they crave it
seems to me is the actual making of the
money you know you got it not the money
itself yeah you can only spend it on
certain things you know what once once
you've spent it on you know you can have
a private island you can have a nice
house on a private island you can have a
yet and a hell yeah yeah exactly and and
and once you've you can have a Ferrari
and then you can have a slightly better
Ferrari and also a Range Rover and then
a one with tinted windows and that you
run out of things to buy pretty quickly
and
so the it was that process of making
money that was so exciting is it that's
something quite profound I think there
that the richest people in the world are
some of the richest people in the world
who have more money than they can ever
spend are not
what they're not doing is focusing on
the money they're not focusing on the
outcome they're focusing on the journey
and yet we look at these people and we
think I want the end of that journey I
don't want the hockey stick it's almost
like they're keeping that grinding
mentality going because that where the
pleasure is actually brought from right
another thing as well as the the
virtuous mean I've been throwing this
around recently that where absolutist
beings right if you tell me to have one
biscuit out of a packet it's really hard
if you tell me to have none or all of
them that's actually quite easy find it
quite easy to have no budget or all the
because it's a very sharp line in the
sand right whereas just to have one to
have enough but not too much is really
challenging had a neuroscientist on
talking about the seven deadly sins you
know like the fundamental problem with
humanity and every single one of them is
fixed by sloth you need a little bit but
not too much rough you need a little bit
but not too much less a little bit but
not too much and it's the same it's the
same greed spoke a lot about greed on
that as well you need a little bit you
need to get yourself over the inertia of
having nothing but when you push
yourself forward and you chase it too
much it becomes as anything you turn a
tonic into a toxin you pathologize the
thing which liberated you into something
which is now actually a prison yeah
absolutely
and there I looked into I wondered what
greed was and and you've got this
Michael Douglas greed is good you know
in in and that's in that film Wall
Street where he he says greed is what's
gonna save us Greed's what's gonna make
America great etcetera and
and and what that's going back to Adam
Smith which is you know if everybody
does what you know seeks what they want
then in a way you all come together and
find the value of everything and
everybody knows what they need to
provide to make themselves some money
and it's a self-generate it's an
emergent system and of course that's
true up to a point I actually won't
began to wonder what that point was and
where things started that's a good
question
where do we how do we draw that line
well I looked I looked into the history
of money the the whole idea of
prosperity is that once we start to
exchange things ie trade we naturally
start to specialize and people who are
good at things end up doing what they're
good at and so at the top end you've got
everybody who's good at something is
doing that thing and they're also
because they only have to do that thing
and they can they can outsource all of
the other things and they they tend to
become inventive so if you raise if
you're good at raising chickens just say
and pretty soon you're gonna find out
that you know if you feed them this they
get a bit bigger quicker and if you feed
that the male's a different one diet
from the females then you'll get more
eggs or whatever it is and you wouldn't
have known that if you haven't
specialized so when everybody's
specializing you get all of this
innovation and then you get more and
more trades and that leads to more
innovation etc so swapping things is
great when you have money swapping
things is easy because they find a price
and we can all agree on what the money
is worth and I think that the thing that
starts confusing people is when you
start applying that to money itself so
when you start applying you know trading
and specialization to the exchange of
money and financial products it seems to
me that people can't get their heads
around it
in the same way that they can get their
heads round trading money for goods
trading money for money you get you get
bubbles and crashes but orders of
magnitude they're right you right
multiplying the thing by the
manipulation of the thing yes exactly so
so it's acceleration rather than speed
or whatever it's it's things taking off
where's Talib what about him nothing we
need to work out which when with me and
you were fumbling our way through
probably to him grade one mathematics
trying to way exam and I need we need to
ring him and say nothing what's the
what's the word for this mate the thing
is that some people like him do and this
it doesn't do their head in but but most
people it does and and and you know the
people who work in them in money in
banks they'll often I mean as a pure
example if you look at rogue traders
like Nick Leeson and many others Peter
Young all sorts of other people who
started making bets and then they went a
bit crazy they did that they kept on
making bets that were losing and they
become like gamblers chasing their
losses a lot of bankers have that
problem they don't they're not
unemotional mathematical machines who
can who can say look I I need to invest
in this lose a bit of money so I
understand how it works and then see
where I can make the big money they just
end up being all it getting emotional
and chucking a lot of money away and
when lots of people are betting like
that you get this kind of mayhem and
sometimes all this value is wiped off
the system and nobody really understands
where it's gone and now when it's
machines that are doing that I mean half
the time it's machines that are doing
that and and I remember reading this
account of
so-called flash crash where algorithms
kind of became confused and they lost
billions in about half a second and when
was this 2009 that there was some
problem with our algorithms you know
that they're programmed they're
instructed to do you know this in that
this circumstance and if if this then do
that and if that then do the other and
normally these these reflect quite
sensible ideas but when it all happens
so fast and they're sort of interlocking
robots and they don't understand each
other you know there is a problem and in
this case it magically reasserted itself
because the algorithm somehow managed to
see what was happening and claw it back
before it completely annihilated the
mark yeah the yeah and me okay so we've
just touched on him there we've danced
around him a couple of bits
Nassim Taleb very very what do you call
him the hottest thinker on the planet I
was saying that that that's what he this
he Kate when I interviewed him I saw him
a few times and I think the Sunday Times
had called him the hottest thinker on
the planet and it was at a time when he
was when people like David Cameron were
asking his advice and
see the big short that movie he's not in
it but he represents those people who
who could see that there was something
wrong with a housing market what was
happening wasn't sustainable and and it
had to end and when it ended or even
when it started to change a bit even
when it flattened out every all all the
houses would come onto the market they
would lose value and all the people all
the different funds that had invested in
those mortgages would find that they
were underwater and all the banks that
were relying on those funds for short
term money so they could keep their and
it was this big kind of circular you
know and a few people who were sort of
Outsiders spotted that this was bound to
happen and I mean Michael burry was one
of them who was featured in the big show
now these were people who weren't it
part of the crowd you know that and the
thing about talib is that he was brought
up in Lebanon and he's now about 60 so
when he was about 20 there was this
terrible war in Lebanon and everybody
said to him oh yeah this is we
occasionally have these wars don't worry
it'll be over by Christmas you know and
then it wasn't and it just kept on
dragging on and nobody predicted that
that this would be such a long-term
immensely destructive conflict
nobody could sort of bear to imagine
that the whole world of Lebanon would
would change and even when they saw it
happening they were still wanting to
hold on to the belief that oh you know
it's going to be alright soon and so he
began to think
weird things happen things that people
don't want to believe will happen but
it's not just that it's that these weird
things are the triggers of history so
nobody thought the First World War was
going to be a four year kind of
bloodbath they thought it was going to
be a few months in fact it it's almost
like an accidental war it's like this
treaty meant that this country had to
say I'm gonna back that country if you
do this and all these treaties this
complex system sort of clicked into
place and suddenly you're having a war
in France and Belgium that has brought
half of Europe into it yeah and it sees
no sign of stopping and what the hell is
that all about and so it's this this
thing that changed history that nobody
was expecting and he began to think God
you know these weird things that nobody
predicts now I would say we're in one of
them now he has said oh you know this
isn't a Black Swan he calls them black
swans
he's unexpected but very important
events and he says this isn't a Black
Swan because people predicted it and
actually I think well yeah technically
but it's really not did a few people
predict it it's what does the world at
large think and I think we weren't
prepared for this I mean I actually
wrote an article about Sir about flu
epidemics just a general thinking it was
in normal yeah I was reviewing a book
and the headline was something like what
about are we prepared for the next one
and I didn't even think about it
somebody had put that headline in now I
can send this article to people then say
look look at me I'm a clairvoyant from
that for sure
but the point is I I didn't I would you
know no way did I think of this as a
real thing I just thought yeah we've had
these flu
epidemics some of them take off and some
of them don't the last one that really
took off was in 1918 let's look at the
reasons for this but nobody had planned
for it and and Talib's argument was all
sorts of histories basically dominated
by these unexpected moments and so if
you know how to position yourself to
deal with them you can make a ton of
money if you're in the markets so that
that was his basic thing but in the end
you know he made a ton of money but
wanted to get out of just trading and
get into sort of thinking about history
and that's what he's done since 2009 I
guess what was it that you the the
summary that you gave to do with how
people don't like to be wrong or they
don't like to be proved wrong so they
always presume that the same things
going to repeat I carry on well yeah
it's kind of like you've got two ways of
investing and you would imagine they
balanced each other out so you can
invest in things that you think are
going to get better and so you can put
money into things that are going to get
better and if you're right then you'll
mostly get small returns back all the
time but then when the thing crashes you
you might blow up you might lose the lot
on the other hand you can bet on things
getting worse and most of the time they
don't so you're losing money all the
time but when they do get worse you make
your big killing and the point is that
these things aren't mirror images of
each other because because people it's
cheaper to invest in things going up
than it is to invest in things going
down because not many P it's a lonely
place to be losing money every day in in
in the hope that everything crashes so
not many people do it
so it turns out the odds are better and
the the remote the returns are bigger
it's a bit like with job safety you know
Safety's overpriced so people can people
can a lot of people want a job for life
so that prepared to be underpaid for it
yeah yeah exactly and it turns out that
it's actually probably safer to do
something else
those those jobs as proven by the fact
that we're in the middle of a chaotic
global pandemic actually aren't all that
safe they're not hugely safe industries
to be so what did you learn if you could
sort of synopsize what your time with
talib and you know a little bit of
one-on-one time with that man would be
very envied by a lot of people on this
planet you know as you mentioned David
Cameron government and politicians
asking his advice what did you I mean is
it learning about being prepared to be
in the out-group to remove your emotions
from the situation what was it yeah
that's that's interesting I think it's I
think what he says is in a way it sums
up what all the other people do it's
kind of have a deep understanding of
something you have to put you have to
sink a lot of money and a lot of time
into understanding things and then when
they move they move fast so it's it's
kind of like nothing happens and then
everything happens who was it that said
you know nothing have most decades
nothing had happened but there are some
weeks in which decades happen like it
was that Churchill who say that was it
was someone Russian there's another one
which I absolutely adore which I'm gonna
miss Kwon I'm gonna bother trying to
quote who it's from but the quote is
history doesn't crawl it leaps yeah well
that's exactly right this is a likely
evolutionary pattern you know things
change animals change into new species
but it's not like a gradual progression
it's much more like nothing much happens
and then there's a leap
and they become something new and maybe
they'll survive and maybe they won't as
that new thing so that's another thing
things happen in in leaps and bounds the
things that are important are often
unexpected and history is all about
these weird unexpected things so if you
X if you try to expect the unexpected
you'll do a lot better because nobody
else is looking and I suppose as you
identified before we have this comfort
predisposition even for bankers who must
have an idea that there's a potential
boom-bust cycle you know they're not
going to be completely ignorant to it
there's certainly gonna be at least a
little bit better informed than the
normal proletariat on the street but
because we have this predisposition
because we don't like to think about bad
things happening we tend to not fully
account for the effect of them occurring
and that's that leads to it's just like
a sweep it under the rug type thing I
put it behind the Wardrobe no one's ever
gonna see yes yes and it's like what
we're in this crisis now and most people
talk about it as if well we've it's
we're done now it's nearly done and you
get the occasional person saying do you
realize that we're at the very beginning
we don't even understand what it is that
we're up against and sure it might
vanish into thin air but it might be ten
years of readjusting and reinventing the
way that society work do you think that
there is a limit to
where we should put positive thought
that naturally I have quite a
catastrophic mentality which I think I
inherited it's a half genetic half
socialized so I tend toward negative
thought but I've worked quite hard to
overcome that right I've worked quite
hard with doing gratitude to actually
have a more positive mindset and turn
things around but when you start to
scale that either across societies
across countries across policymaking or
just maybe scale it across people is
there kind of an upper bound on how much
we should be pushing that level of sort
of it's all bright and rosy just look to
the silver lining I guess you have to go
Matt imagine because we haven't evolved
much since we had you know very very
rudimentary tools and lived in a groups
of a hundred and fifty and I guess you
you needed people didn't you to say we
could get across that River we did we
would just need I don't know
and once we're over there that the Bison
they're much bigger and you need it
people to say yes you're right we'll
we'll bloody well do it we can get
across this ravine but you needed some
pessimistic depressed people to say oh
are you kidding me not this again do you
remember when we lasted it and all that
people fell in and it was terrible so
you need a mixture of people don't you
in a mixture of emotions yeah and I mean
there's an awful lot of have you ever
ready in McGilchrist no what should I
read he wrote this book called the
master in his emissary and it's all
about the two sides of the brain but
it's the take away thing is that you
know part of our brains are looking out
at nature that's what they do that's
what they did for two hundred thousand
years they looked out at nature at the
sky and the rain and the clouds and
their you know the trees and all this
all the time they're looking at it
nature and the other side of the brain
is thinking how can I make a tool out of
that you know I could chop that branch
off and then it would be this big and if
I chopped it in half I could then join
them together and and that's what the
other side of the brain is thinking and
of course the that side of the brain the
left side that the tool-making side
begins to make more and more tools and
until what the right side is looking at
is not so much nature but tools you go
into a city and you're looking at tools
you're looking at cars and computers and
and you know telegraph poles and then
you're making tools out of those tools
the left side saying yeah how could I
make tools out of those tools oh I know
I could sell them in advance and then
charge interest and then come you know
and and so of course we have we have
sort of created a new environment that
were not quite we're not quite up with
yet and I said I suppose because it's so
safe as well because we know yeah we
don't have that fewer people are falling
into the ravine
and more people are making it across on
the log and then the tool the tools to
the power of tools is a cool concept I
like that it makes me think about the
financial products that we were talking
about and they're like exactly houses to
the package of mortgages to the package
of bonds to the package of data to do
all the way up right so final thing
final question you spent all this time
other people Nassim Taleb been a Russian
billionaire and his Butler and a Jordan
Belfort wolf of wallstreet so what did
you learn about money what did they
teach you are you rich now no I've never
well no yeah I've never been rich I've
been richer than you know many people
but I don't think I'll ever be
fabulously rich and I I could I could be
comfortable if I if I keep a if I you
have put a break on my spending which of
course I have done now because I can't
even go to the shops so also I don't you
know all of those things that say if
you've got enough money that you're not
frightened of you know people knocking
on your door you can't get much better
than that you know I've got a nice nice
ish car I could get a nicer car would it
make me happier not really I could get a
fabulous car would it make me happier
not really I'd be I'd be sick of it in a
week and I'd think yeah
it's okay my old car was pretty good too
I didn't really bother about that that
was fine so I'm aware that obsessing
about it isn't the way to go you know
what what you want to be rich in this
time and also your relationships with
other people and being obsessed with
money can take those things away so you
what you want to use your time you want
to know that you're using your time well
and I think you feel it if you're
learning things if you spend your life
learning things and spending time with
people talking and all of this that's
great and you think yourself well if I
had an extra ten grand in my pocket
would I feel happier and not much it
wouldn't it wouldn't have enhanced you
know you could go to a restaurant with
people and have a great time and if you
had twice as much money you could say
yeah I won the best champagne you know
but that might be a distraction and it
it's not necessarily gonna make anybody
any happier really of course people are
gonna go back and say do you know what I
had the best champagne but that would
have been really a distraction I once
went to this this I was reviewing this
resort where the wine was so expensive
that I think I drank $1,000 of wine and
I wasn't even a bit drunk you know the
point of this is back when I drank but
the point is that yeah you could spend
it what I wasn't spending the money but
it was you know the money was being
spent on my behalf incidentally but I
could have it would have taken me a
couple of grand to get paid you know and
this is a resort for very the super-rich
and of course they go there and they
think a wonderful look this bottle of
wines a grand they've got the cheap
stuff here darling they've got the cheap
and you know all of that is once you've
seen it it's like okay fair enough so so
was that was that the answer to your
question
so I said well let me let me see if I
can repurpose it into let me see if I
can try and define what I think that was
having money is a comfort and is useful
in that it liberates your time to spend
doing things that you want to do with
people that you want to do it with yeah
but of course you've got to be the
person who can use that time well and if
you spend all your time making money you
might find that you've got you do get to
buy yourself some time but you don't
know what to do with it because you just
want to be making more money so so you
you know that there are things you can
spend your time doing Felix Dennis who
had thought about this a lot because he
he felt he'd ruined his life with money
in some ways and he said something like
you know if I write something I haven't
wasted my time but if I buy something I
might be sick of it and I might feel
it's not really gonna help me you know
spending money isn't the answer whereas
sort of making something makes you a lot
happier but doesn't that speak to what
we what we touched on earlier as well
about it's the process of becoming not
being or having yeah that's right yes as
soon as you're drunk or rich
you've reached the finish line is that
the rule of thumb as soon as you're
drunk or rich you've reached the finish
line what what I mean is if you're if
you're a drinker it's the getting drunk
and if you're a if you're a tycoon it's
the making of the money but it if you
were to place all these people in their
luxurious habitats and say right there
you are you can spend the rest of your
time sitting by your infinity pool
drinking your thousand thousand pound
wine and and have an and having you know
if you want to drive your Rolls Royce
you don't even need to reverse it
because your garage has a rotating floor
and that Felix Dennis had this he had
his role model Gareth put into a
rotating garage so that you could almost
be pointing outwards you know you didn't
have to do that pesky thing of reversing
into what was actually quite a big Drive
or what you know it's not like there was
a cramped space to reverse him - but you
wouldn't even have to bother reversing
because you could just make the garage
rotate so you know you can buy an
endless number of those things but they
have diminishing returns don't they and
it's really something else something
much more elusive that will make you
happy I love that I really do I hope I'm
continuing to drill this into the
listeners heads the hedonic treadmill
that we're all on and the fact that if
it's not a study saying that anything
over 56,000 pounds doesn't have
increases in happiness it only as
increases in satisfaction or whether
it's you speaking to the smartest or
richest people on the planet or you know
Morgan Housel from collaborative fund
and The Motley Fool telling us that all
that money does is give you time to
spend with people that you like doing
the things that you want to do you know
how many different directions do we need
to hear this from before we can start to
kind of rid ourselves of this
materialistic predisposition that we all
have maybe just that one more podcast
that we've done William so the trick out
now available Amazon
yes yes are there good bookstores you
can buy it you can download it and you
can listen to an audio version which I
was really pleased with I didn't read it
by the way who did you get to read it
well it's a guy called rich people and
his voice is a bit like Jack Dee so it
sounds like my book read by Jack Dee
with that kind of I don't know it's just
perfect
and I actually emailed him and said my
God thank you so much
so it's worth listening to the audiobook
- amazing link is in the show notes
below if you want to buy it through that
you will be supporting the podcast at no
extra cost to yourself if you don't
already have an audible subscription I
recommend that you go and get one and if
you do that you can actually get this
book for free just because you get your
first book for free which is amazing and
you still get paid so that's a great way
to do it look William man thank you so
much a final final point for the people
that are just watching have a look at
how beautiful the cover of this book is
you will see it if you're walking
through water stones or in the airport
or whatever you will see this no one's
in an airport the moment actually are
you're never going to be in a water
stones either in 2022 when we finally
reopen you will be able to see it in an
airport but look William thank you so
much for your time it's been great man
thank you
you
[Music]